ja wir müssen wir richten über eine
messerattacke mitten in einem
ausländeramt zwar auf eine mitarbeiterin
passiert ist diese wahnsinnstat in
wuppertal elberfeld am frühen morgen
griff dort ein 21 jähriger syrer die
frau an der mann stürmte ins sogenannte
haus der integration dort sprang der
angreifer im eingangsbereich über den
empfangstresen und stach dann
unvermittelt auf die frau ein der
sicherheitsdienst der konnte ihn dann
schließlich überwältigen der mann wurde
später von der polizei festgenommen
die frau ist inzwischen im krankenhaus
wie schwer sie verletzt ist ist derzeit
noch unklar im haus der integration hin
sowohl der jobcenter als auch das
ausländeramt untergebracht und
zugeschaltet in wuppertal ist uns jetzt
andreas wegener unser reporter vor ort
und was kannst du uns zu den
hintergründen der tat sagen
ja man muss einfach sagen zu den
hintergründen kann noch nicht viel
gesagt werden man muss sich überlegen
diese tat dies kann mal hier gut vier
stunden her der junge mann der
festgenommen worden ist der wird jetzt
durch anwälte beraten die zeugen sind
zum teil traumatisiert und konnte noch
nicht befragt werden insofern muss man
vielleicht verständnis haben dass die
kripo da mit schnellen antworten noch
nicht dabei ist was aber auch klar ist
der tatort hier dass seine ausländer
würde und in der ausländerbehörde da
geht es natürlich für die leute die da
hilfe suchen um existenzielle sachen da
geht es ums bleiberecht zum beispiel und
da kommt es natürlich häufiger mal zu
streit und deshalb ist ja eben auch
dieser sicherheitsdienst hier schon seit
langer zeit beschäftigt weiß man denn
inzwischen etwas zum zustand der frau
wie es ihr geht schwebt sie in
lebensgefahr
ja da gab es zum glück entwarnung aus
dem krankenhaus also ich habe gerade
noch mal mit der polizei gesprochen es
sieht wohl so aus dass sie schwer
verletzt ist da jetzt behandelt wird
aber zum glück muss ich nicht befürchten
dass sie stirbt muss niemand befürchten
dass sie stirbt insofern das kann man
jetzt schon sagen aber weitere details
werden moment halt auch nämlich bekannt
gegeben also eine messerattacke
ausgerechnet im haus der integration
was natürlich von bitterer ironie es in
der andreas wegner